total énergie au chant renault ou encore
leroy merlin plusieurs entreprises
françaises qui ont des intérêts et des
salariés en russie sont confrontés à ce
dilemme rester ou partir la pression de
l'opinion française et internationale
est forte mais les solutions ne sont pas
simples avant d'en débattre un état des
lieux signé sandra cerqueira
mercredi dernier devant le parlement le
président ukrainien exhorte les
entreprises françaises implantées en
russie a quitté le pays
les entreprises françaises doivent
quitter le marché russe rno auchan
leroy-merlin doivent cesser d'être les
sponsors de la machine de guerre de la
russie
cible des critiques de zemlinsky seul
renault a décidé de stopper
temporairement ses activités dans son
usine de moscou les autres sociétés
françaises encore active en russie
temporise et espère une fin rapide du
conflit en ukraine c'est le cas du
groupe mulliez qui possède les enseignes
auchan leroy merlin et décathlon
le groupe a décidé de se maintenir en
russie justifiant son choix par la
nécessité de ne pas condamner leurs
équipes sur place danone bonduelle
société générale sont également encore
présentes en russie total énergie aussi
même si le groupe prévoit d'arrêter tout
achat de pétrole dans les meilleurs
délais ou au plus tard fin 2022 selon
bercy la france est le premier employeur
en russie avec quelques 160 mille
salariés partir ou rester une décision
loin d'être sans conséquence pour ces
entreprises le gouvernement a décidé de
leur laisser le choix ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ya des entreprises
françaises qui sont en russie qu'elles
font des choix qu'elle doit appliquer
les sanctions qui sont fixés et elles le
font on n'a pas demandé aux entreprises
étrangères ce soit la france où les
autres pays de quitter la russie en
revanche qu'on leur a demandé est ce qui
est appliqué par les entreprises
françaises c'est de ne pas s'engager
dans de nouveaux investissements en
russie à partir de là ça devienne
décision de chaque entreprise dans ce
bras de fer vladimir poutine laisse
planer une menace
nationalisé les activités des
entreprises qu'ils quitteraient le pays
plusieurs milliards d'euros sont en jeu
pour les entreprises françaises
je le disais tout rester ou partir la
question elle est binaire mais la
réponse elle nécessite l'expertisé de
mes invités sylvie matelly bonsoir
économistes directrice adjointe de
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques
olivier babeau bon soit le président
institut sapiens professeur en sciences
de gestion à l'université de bordeaux et
auteur de nouveaux désordres numérique
comment le digital fait exploser les
inégalités c'est publié aux éditions
buchet chastel j'accueille également
olivier doran bonsoir bienvenue avocat
spécialiste des sanctions économiques
matthieu croissandeau est évidemment
rester à mes côtés
je peux pas ne pas vous poser la
question générale même s'il ya sans
doute autant de réponses que
d'entreprises parce que à chaque
entreprise un cas particulier sylvie
matelly vous répondez quoi vous à la
question rester ou partir
c'est la bonne question la question que
tout le monde se pose est ce que
quiconque a une réponse c'est plus
compliqué
ce qu'on constate en tout cas c'est que
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même une
pression croissante
au filet et de crise et dans toutes les
crises des société civile et des partis
prônent sommes des entreprises pour
respecter un certain nombre de principes
et je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
a été mal appréhendé mal anticipé par
les entreprises qui font depuis des
années une politique de rse de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale mais qui ont oublié
finalement de réfléchir à la façon dont
on transposait cette politique à
l'international donc ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est qu'il ya une
certaine forme d'un préparation face au
des entreprises face aux crises
géopolitiques après on pourrait faire le
parallèle avec les états les états
européens qui sont plus dépendantes du
gaz que jamais et qui avait
vraisemblablement pas anticipé non plus
ce qui allait se passer oui sont les
entreprises sont radisson à ne pas avoir
suffisamment anticipé mais effectivement
il ya ce mouvement donc la rse
responsabilité sociale sociétale
environnementale les le mouvement des de
la doua pacte c'est à dire les
entreprises qui définissent une raison
des depuis qu'ils deviennent entreprises
à mission c'est sans doute lié d'abord
entre encore plus difficile dans un
contexte comme celui-là avec une
pression des réseaux sociaux qu'on
connaît et qu'on voit à l'oeuvre partout
de résister et de répondre
je reste à la question faut-il rester ou
partir de quitter la russie oui on
assiste au prolongement assez logique de
cette tendance grandissante exiger des
entreprises qu'elles s'engagent elles
s'engagent écologiquement elles
s'engagent socialement maintenant de
reparler de rse paix puisque maintenant
il ya une responsabilité politique c'est
à dire que on veut qu'elles reflètent
évidemment les choix politiques les
choix de valeurs c'était déjà un peu le
cas évidemment on exiger qu'on soit pas
dans certains pays c'est est
désapprouvée mais là on voit bien que
c'est organiser leur salle encore plus
aux états unis où il ya carrément d
entre des universités qu'ont publié des
classements un bon et mauvais et ça
c'est évidemment ça a un effet
extrêmement fort parce que le risque
c'est ce que vous perdez sur place mais
c'est aussi le boycott à l'intérieur et
que ça n'est quand même parti en
laissant trois 13 ou 14 milliards de
dollars d'investissements sur place bah
il estimait que le boycott dans leur
pays était un danger supplémentaire est
ce que les parlant de l' impression qu
est ce que les entreprises
anglo-saxonnes réagissent plus vite face
à cette menace d'après vous aussi il
faudrait regarder au cas par cas ce qui
est vrai c'est que les entreprises
américaines ont une pression plus forte
pour ce genre de choses nous on est un
petit peu en retard et il faut dire
aussi peut-être que nous nos engagements
sont plus forts nos liens sont beaucoup
plus forts l europe est un très très
grand partenaire de la russie et dans
les deux sens et donc c'est évident pas
très facile de partir du jour évidemment
la france en russie quatrième
investisseur étranger derrière les etats
unis le royaume uni de l'allemagne il ya
500 entreprises françaises qui sont en
plate et dont 35 sur les 40 plus grandes
entreprises 1 35 entreprises du cac 40
et la france est le premier employeur
étranger en russie avec 260 mille
salariés donc c'est aussi ainsi très
important on y est on y reviendra
olivier dorgan il faut peut-être poser
un peu ce décor en termes juridiques
serieys des contraintes juridiques qui
pèsent sur sur ces entreprises et sur
ses grands coups francs swiss et ses
lacets l'analogie du martray de
l'enclume qui pour le coup est très
approprié dans le contexte géopolitique
on a à la fois et c'est ce que rappelait
gabriela talent des règles qui de toute
manière on forcer certaines entreprises
françaises à quitter le territoire russe
parce qu'elle exerçait dans des secteurs
d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui
sanctionner au niveau européen et on a
et on en parle beaucoup moins et c'est à
mon sens le une des questions qui
devraient être apportées aux débats des
contre-mesures ruche depuis maintenant
quasiment en moi depuis le 28 février
pour être précis qui rend très difficile
la sortie de ces entreprises du
territoire russe et c'est assez propre
d'ailleurs la manière dont ces
entreprises ont investi en russie parce
qu'il faut aussi tous les entreprises
n'ont pas investi la même manière et les
entreprises qui ont développé des
franchises des entreprises qui ont
ouvert des filiales ou des branches il
ya des entreprises qui ont par ailleurs
fait des partenariats et sur cette
question des partenariats la france est
peut-être un petit peu différente de ses
partenaires européens il ya beaucoup de
partenariats qui ont été signés on pense
à renault mais on pense également à
total et d'autres entreprises et ses
partenariats aujourd'hui d'un point de
vue juridique en russie ne peuvent pas
être rompu sans l'accord du gouvernement
et cette mesure était prise quasiment
immédiatement après le début des
hostilités pour justement figé les
investissements étrangers au sein de la
russie pour éventuellement on va
peut-être plus tard ce soir les
nationaliser si vladimir poutine décidé
d'aller jusque-là et mathieu si on
revient sur les différents discours de
l'onu mr zelensky devant lé parlement il
n'a pas forcément cibler les grandes
entreprises nationales à chaque fois si
on fait un peu de communication
politique ou de communication générale
il a quand même mis dans le mille en
utilisant cette cette image là devant je
le rappelle le parlement c'est-à-dire et
le sénat et l'assemblée nationale en
simultané en visioconférence est en
pleine campagne présidentielle en pleine
campagne présidentielle il a choisit ses
cibles la décence à celles qui sont les
plus implantées là bas et
sur la question que vous posez thomas
est sain il partir ou rester je pense
qu'il faut surtout l'expliquer et quel
que soit votre choix et là les
explications qu'on a sur pourquoi on
reste par exemple chez total energy ou
chez leroy merlin sont pas du tout les
mêmes chez total derrière nrj patrick
pouyanné dj mis beaucoup d'argent j'ai
quand même pas perdre tout cet argent
vous faire cadeau de cet argent russe
caricature mais c'est un peu près son
propos leroy merlin et le groupe udc
attendez on fait ça par solidarité avec
tous nos équipes et tous nos
collaborateurs sur place ce qui est sûr
c'est quand on met le doigt là dedans ce
qu'est ce qui est un autre argument mais
je mets quand on met le doigt là dedans
ça peut provoquer un
un effet domino parce que quitter la
russie d'accord mais est-ce que total
doit quitter la birmanie est ce que
total ou doit quitter les régimes qui
sont pas toujours fréquentable où ils
ont fait de l'argent on voit bien que
pour eux cdc c'est s'exposer à une à des
risques systémiques sur la
quasi-totalité de ses six exemplaires
qui est produit des hydrocarbures dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui alors si on si on
fait un focus sur les différents cas de
figure des entreprises françaises alors
il ya celles qui ont annoncé vouloir
quitter la russie vous les voyez sa
fille chez renault bnp paribas crédit
agricole lvmh kering hermès airbus
safran et alstom ensuite il ya celles
qui ont dit et vous en avez citer
quelques-unes on reste leroy merlin
auchan donc là c'est le groupe heuliez
un des quatre non c'était
là aussi le goût de milieux aisés puis
société générale et blabla quart et puis
les entreprises qui suspendent leurs
investissements et là on peut citer
total energy sanofi danone et l'oréal je
viens que steve jourda qui doit être pas
très loin en coulisses nous nous
rejoignent rebond soir steve c'est quoi
on a un tout petit peu évoquée mais je
veux vraiment qu'on rentre dans le
détail avec vous les arguments
principaux qui sont mis en avant pour
justifier la décision de rester en
russie ont recommandé la tuera disons
clairement pour le moment aucune
entreprise française opérant en russie
n'a vraiment quitté le pays un certain
nombre d'entre elles vous l'avez évoqué
thomas se sont simplement contenté de
suspendre leurs activités c'est le cas
par exemple de renault qui jeudi dernier
a annoncé suspendre ses activités dans
son usine de moscou suspension donc et
non un arrêt total pour l'instant des
activités en russie de son côté total
énergie ne fait pour l'instant ni l'un
ni l'autre elle ne compte pas
l'entreprise quitté la russie pourquoi
et bien parce que cela reviendrait selon
son patron est bien à faire un cadeau à
vladimir poutine écoutez le
aujourd'hui j'ai personnes en russie
contrairement à ce qu'il dit je n'ai pas
d'opération aussi ce que j'ai en russie
c'est qu'on a investi dans des usines
pour presque 13 milliards de dollars et
c'est pas un problème d'argent c'est que
sais-je usines elles vont continuer à
tourner que je m'en aille ou non les
russes les font tourner très bien
et deuxièmement me retirer ces données
ces 13 milliards à des russes parce que
je suis pour parce qu'aujourd'hui
personne ne veut acheter ses usines et
donc je vais enrichir les russes ceux
contre lesquels on veut donner des
sanctions voilà partir ça reviendrait
selon certains patrons à aboutir à
l'effet inverse sein d'une sanction ces
entreprises s'exposerait par exemple un
risque d'expropriation est ce que ce
risque est réel poutine l'a déjà fait
outin a déjà fait c'était en 2003 et ça
concernait le groupe pétrolier ioukos un
groupe russe en partie détenues par les
investisseurs étrangers ioukos qui était
alors dirigée aussi par un oligarque
ennemis déclarés de vladimir poutine
alors est ce que vladimir poutine
pourrait et bien par exemple expropriés
total aux champs ou encore leroy merlin
en théorie oui complètement rien ne
l'interdît l'expropriation c'est en
quelque sorte une arme d etat contre des
entreprises étrangères l'exemple
historique le plus célèbre c'est
peut-être bien la nationalisation du
canal de suez 1956 nationalisation
égyptienne contre les intérêts français
contre les intérêts britanniques
nationalisation qui avait d'ailleurs
abouti thomas unger et si vous devez
dire poutine décide d'exproprier des
entreprises françaises est ce qu'il peut
le faire sans les indemniser sans aucune
contrepartie financière oui c'est ce que
pointe un d'ailleurs beaucoup de
spécialistes si c'est le cas ces
entreprises pourront toujours ensuite se
tourner vers la justice internationale
pour demander une compensation mais la
justice la justice internationale ça
prend du temps beaucoup de temps je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de l'exemple du
groupe ioukos poutine a exproprié donc
en 2003 les actionnaires ont entamé des
poursuites en 2014 coup de théâtre
finalement et bien
les actionnaires ont été dédommagés en
tout cas le tribunal de la haye a
demandé à ce que la russie était 50
milliards de dollars de dédommagement à
ses actionnaires exproprier condamnation
record le kremlin a fait appel de cette
décision aujourd'hui que 20 ans après la
saga judiciaire continue encore et
toujours devant les tribunaux merci
steve je vous signale que le le
président de total energy patrick
pouyanné sera l'invité de l'émission
pourvu que ça dure ce mercredi à 17h30
première interview télévisée il avait
donné une interview dans l huile extrait
la rtl mais c'est une exclusivité
télé et voilà ce sera évidemment un
moment important deux de cette semaine
olivier doran et est ce qu'on va voir
forcément je rebondis sur ce que vient
de dire steve fleurir des contentieux
internationaux entre les groupes
français ou d'autres d'ailleurs il a et
la russie clairement pas ce que la
russie avait déjà exproprié par le passé
mais la russie est sur le point
d'adopter une loi qui va alors c'est pas
une nationalisation parce que la russie
a peut-être appris de ses erreurs
notamment du 2-1 fameux caillou cos qui
est toujours en cours mais elle va
pouvoir nommer des mandataires
judiciaires indépendants qui seront
russe par essence quand une entreprise
et c'est là qu'il a tous une ambiguïté
juridique ce sera d'exploiter son
activité en russie de manière convenable
avec et là je reste sur cette ambiguïté
vantard parce que le texte est à peu
près de cette ambiguïté en russe et donc
elle un outil juridique complémentaires
dont elle entend faire usage parce que
je ne vois pas pourquoi le président
poutine aurait demandé à la douma de
plancher sur ce sur cette nouvelle loi
qui vient renforcer les dispositifs
existants et au delà de ça et moi je
pense ou d'un autre point qui est assez
peu couverts dans les médias occidentaux
c'est le renforcement aussi de la
responsabilité pénale des dirigeants
la russie avait déjà dans son code pénal
un article qui permettait de poursuivre
en dirigeant notamment expatriés pour
une liquidation ou une mise en
liquidation volontaire qui seraient
frauduleuses et là en l'occurrence
depuis le cas de marcy également une loi
qui pourrait permettre de condamner en
colonie pénitentiaire des expatriés
occidentaux qui en appliquant des
sanctions européennes par exemple
ces thrillers activités en russie ça
veut dire que les patrons français dont
on parle là des grands groupes qu'on a
cité il risque une peine
à titre personnel ou autres personnels
en homicide et qui sont ce temps qu'ils
sont sur le territoire russe oui parce
que vous imaginez bien que la france
n'extrade raja me revient cesser ses
ressortissants va interdire est d'aller
en russie grâce à leur interdirait
d'aller en russie mais c'est vrai que
c'est je rebondis un peu sinon c'est sûr
qu'on entend parler un peu de tout à
l'heure ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est dans la communication des
entreprises j'entends beaucoup de choses
j'entends effectivement des éléments
réputationnel des éléments économiques
mais j'entends pas d'éléments juridiques
et je me pose la question de savoir
pourquoi parce que ça pourrait être
relativement audible si on le dit de
manière assez simple pour un groupe
comme l'euro 2016 par exemple expliqué
que quand bien même il se pose la
question de savoir s'il est pertinent ou
non pour le groupe dresse en russie il
lui est juridiquement aujourd'hui très
compliqué voire impossible
quoi qu'il en soit de sortir domicile
2-2 mémoire patrick pouyanné sur rtl
il y avait fait référence en parlant de
contrats sur le gaz en dix ans on a des
contrats à 25 ans et s'il n'y a pas une
décision politique d'embargo on peut pas
sortir de ces contrats on aurait à payer
des pénalités très importante est ce que
vous entendez cet argument signe matelly
on va faire le cac total encore quelques
minutes et ensuite le cas au chant c'est
cet argument de patrick périple à dire
si je je pars comme ça brutalement
j'enrichis les russes finalement c'est
contre-productif c'est vrai ou pas c'est
vrai mais en restant ils les enrichit
aussi donc c'est tout le c'est toute la
difficulté de la vàd de la problématique
de fond qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui vaut
mieux partir tout de suite ou au reste
et préserver aussi ses intérêts
financiers ses intérêts économiques sur
place donc c'est clair que c'est une
question complexe je serais bien en
peine de répondre à la place de total et
de ses dirigeants c'est une question
complexe surtout pour des groupes qui
sont des groupes qui sont présentes dans
l'énergie est très présent dans
l'énergie parce que comme vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de pays où
il est à peu près sûr d'investir et de
et de faire ses activités et puis il ne
vous aura pas échappé qu'on est en
pleine transition énergétique total est
en train de révolutionner son activité
ils ont changé le monde émergent effet
d'investir massivement pour changer
cette activité comptait largement sur le
gaz et l'exploitation du gaz pour
parvenir à se passer de pétrole donc
forcément ça oblige aussi à réfléchir à
réorienter cette stratégie et ça prend
un petit peu de temps ce qui peut
expliquer le temps que se donne
l'entreprise aussi pour prendre sa
décision définitive sur la russie
olivier babeau un dernier mot sur sur
total quand patrick cohen et annonce la
fin des investissements
futurs c'est ce qu'on comprend est ce
que c'est un gros sacrifice qu'est ce
que ça représente
ça peut être une façon sans le dire sans
exprimer ainsi 2 est d'attendre parce
que finalement qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui
va se passer personne ne sait ce qui s
est terminé dans deux jours dans une
semaine dans plusieurs mois on peut tous
espérer que ça soit relativement rapide
et les entreprises sans doute attendre
des jours meilleurs est ce que je sais
par le régime de poutine va être de se
terminer et d'ailleurs les entreprises
elles se positionnent dans le temps long
et donc l imagine cette ses
investissements et puis ses relations
avec leurs clients avec des
collaborateurs sur place dans le temps
long elles se disent qu'est ce qui va se
passer le jour où la guerre sera finie
est ce que j'aurai brûlé mais vaisseau
est ce que j'aurais beaucoup de mal à
rétablir la confiance que j'aurais
ll est ce que j'aurai perdu mes
investissements et donc dire qu'on va
pas réinvestir tout de suite c'est une
façon de dire on va voir quelques
semaines ce qui se passe et avec un peu
de chance ça va finir par se tasser
personne ne sait ce qui va se passer
avec deux de jouer un peu la montre
alors ital d'auchan maintenant très
implanté en russie 3,2 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires en 2021 10% du
chiffre d'affaires global de de
l'entreprise de 140 magasins et 30000
salariés ça c'est uniquement pour auchan
je rappelle qu'à d'autres enseignes du
du groupe mulliez zaki qui sont
présentes en russie et puis je vous
propose d'en temps alors là il n'y a pas
eu d interviews radios ou ou télé il ya
eu une interview de presse écrite du
patron du pdg de charité internationale
ihf claude c'était au journal du
dimanche hier je le cite le plus
important à nos yeux est de préserver
nos collaborateurs et d'assurer notre
mission première qui est de continuer à
nourrir les populations dans ces deux
pays on agit pour la population civile
il dit plus loin si auchan par nous
privons d'emploi 30000 personnes qui
sont salariés et actionnaires pour 40%
d'entre elles et enfin partir serait
inimaginable sur un plan économique mais
pas du point de vue serait pardon partir
sur est imaginable sur le plan
économique mais pas du point de vue
humain le groupe auchan peut-il quitter
la russie sans mettre en péril son
avenir si matelly s'apaisent quand on
dit 10% du chiffre d'affaires il
survivra ce à quoi ils survivre est très
certainement à ça surtout qu'on peut
imaginer qu'ils se repositionnerait
ailleurs simplement la crainte c'est de
ne plus pouvoir y retourner puisque on
prend les magasins seraient récupérées
alors vladimir poutine a menacé de
nationaliser d'installer des
entrepreneurs locaux donc c'est clair
que on peut aussi créer un nouveau
concurrent c'est ce qui s'était passé
rappelez-vous avec les sanctions qui
avait imposé la russie sur l'agriculture
et qui ont permis à l'agriculture russe
de ceux de se repositionner sur les
marchés mondiaux et aujourd'hui d'être
le premier exportateur à la russie
d'être le premier exportateur de blé
donc c'est aussi ça qui rentrent en
ligne de compte bien évidemment et 10%
de leur chiffre d'affaires alors ça fait
mal hein c'est pas rien
c'est de la consommation finale donc ça
peut ça doit pouvoir se récupérer un
garde aux leaders dans l'argument
humains les 30000 salariés et russes
dont parle yves claude que leur
arriverait-il si auchan partait
d'ailleurs que alors c'est un peu de
l'économie fiction mais qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer c'est pas forcément
d'économie fiction parce que certains
groupes internationaux non français ont
quitté on annonçait alors il ya
différents scénarios il ya le scénario
de l'équivalent de chômage technique ou
de chômage partiel donc une prise en
charge des salaires pendant un certain
temps justement dans cet attentisme
parce que vous lisiez très justement les
groupes se pose la question de la
temporalité de ces sanctions est de
savoir si oui ou non la russie redonnera
un partenaire commercial fréquentable et
ne veulent pas tout de suite coupé les
ponts de manière définitive notamment
vis-à-vis de leurs employés une autre
option ce serait effectivement de l'es22
les licenciés ffa en tout cas de cesser
son activité donc de les licencier de
fait mais comme le disait très justement
sylvie matelly dans ce cas là et c'est
un peu le sens de ce que propose la
lumière poutine on n'irait de toutes
manière sur une nationalisation et donc
ces gens là se retrouveraient de fête
avec un nouveaux employeurs qu'ils
soient chinois ou riches en cordes
peut-être pour rebondir rapidement sur
sur ce que dit sylvie matelly qui est à
mon sens une analyse très juste les
entreprises aussi ont l'expérience n'est
pas la première fois qu'un pays fait
l'objet de sanctions alors c'est la
preuve qu'un pays dans lequel la france
est aussi implanté fait l'objet de
sanctions ça c'est une évidence mais il
ya d'autres groupes notamment au secteur
de l'énergie qui ont par exemple
réinvesti le marché iranien soit avant
2012 soit entre 2016 et 2018 et qui ont
vu ce que partir rapidement faisais moi
j'ai accompagné une délégation
d'entrepreneurs et des gens du medef en
iran à plusieurs reprises entre 2016 et
2018 et les entreprises n'étaient pas
accueilli à bras ouverts parce que les
chinois s'étaient engouffrés dans ce
marché là et quand vous allez
aujourd'hui à teyran vous avez une ville
qui est beaucoup plus dans sa
consommation asiatique qu'elle n'était
européenne qu'elle ne européenne alors
qu'elle était par le passé bon je pense
que les entre les entreprises françaises
ont cette crainte en tête donc vous
comprenez qu'elle joue la montre pour
reprendre un peu la formule de vivago
jeu quand même même on a cité celle qui
ont annoncé quitter la russie soit 10 et
steve c'est assez il ya l'annoncé puis
il ya les accents un peu de temps quoi
voilà je comprends qu'elles jouent la
montre après jeu là où je suis pas
forcément en phase en termes de
temporalité juridique c'est que quand
bien même demain nous arrivions cessez
le feu et quand bien même demain même le
devenir d'un jeans qui reconnaissait
l'indépendance des problèmes des
provinces de l'est de l'ukraine je ne
suis pas sûr que les sanctions
occidentales tomberez quand on écoute le
discours de joe biden il ya quelques
jours à varsovie on comprend qu'on est
rentrés dans une dynamique de guerre
froide et je ne pense pas que les
entreprises aient encore intégrer cette
notion dans l'art dans leur
planification ce qui montre aussi la
préparation dont parlait s'ils émettent
aignan matière de géopolitique et donc
je pense qu'il serait imprudent de leur
parc de penser retourner sur le marché
russe en tout cas cette année est minime
olivier babeau il ya un autre effet
quels effets sur la le cours de bourse
la capitalisation boursière de de ces
entreprises elles l'ont déjà payé pour
certaines en voyant leurs cours de
bourse baissé parce que les marchés quoi
juge que telle banque la société
générale par exemple est trop exposé aux
risques russe où ça on l'a déjà on voit
déjà à l'oeuvre depuis plusieurs
semaines et c'était assez clair oui vous
étiez un exposé profondément au marché
russe mais kad renault par exemple aussi
puis c'était une part importante de vos
activités et puis de votre recentrage
stratégique de la façon dont vous voyez
l'avenir plus vous voyez l incertitude
qui est totale aujourd'hui
grande et donc peser sur le cours de
bourse sur les perspectives qu on vous
attribue pas ce que ça veut dire
forcément que vous allez avoir des
pertes d'investissements se dire qu'il
va falloir investir ailleurs qu'il va
falloir changer votre fusil d'épaulé ça
prend beaucoup de temps et évidemment
c'est assez coûteux
c'est dur parce que pendant longtemps
des entreprises pouvaient légitimement
imaginer que la russie est un pays qui
aller quelque part s'occidentaliser
qu'ils allaient se normaliser et
évidemment c'est une désillusion assez
cruel encore comme vous l'avez souligné
même chez les décideurs politiques
beaucoup n'avaient pas vu en cette
rupture venir on en est un peu tous
étonnés oui alors vous l'avez dit
mathieu on est au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle également et évidemment
les les candidates et les candidats se
positionne sur cette question deux
candidate à la présidentielle valérie
pécresse est d'abord nathalie arthaud
écouter ceux qui partent font le même
calcul en réalité ce que c'est un calcul
d'image il essaye de préserver leurs
intérêts à long terme et ceux qui
restent font le calcul mais mais mais le
résultat est juste un verre ça qu'ils
ont le courage de leurs portefeuilles
point barre il serait sage aujourd'hui
que les entreprises qui ont les épaules
pour le faire se retire de aussi je ne
dis pas à toutes les entreprises de
france d'arrêter de faire du commerce
avec la russie parce que je pense que il
faut aussi penser aux salariés de ces
entreprises les entreprises qui ont les
épaules dit valérie pécresse sylvie
matelly c'est vrai que depuis ces deux
logiques à on parle toujours des plus
des groupes les plus puissants parle des
35 des 40 ans hugo plus grandes
entreprises françaises mais il y a on a
vu aussi que tout à l'heure il ya 500
entreprises qui sont présentes en russie
est ce que le risque est forcément plus
faible pour elle parce qu'elles sont
moins dans les projecteurs médiatiques
bon vous avez un tout petit peu répondu
hier sur la question de l'engagement
moral de l'engagement politique de la
raison d'être des des entreprises même
les pme peuvent être sur ce chemin là
donc le risque est plus ou moins fort
pour elle qu'est ce que vous diriez non
ça dépend moi je sais pas ce que sont
les épaules des entreprises en fait dans
nos coeurs et je pense pas que ça dépend
de la taille de l'entreprise
non ça dépend de l'exposition et du
positionnement sur place
quand vous êtes uniquement
approvisionnés par par des produits
russes c'est vrai que vous êtes moins
exposée que lorsque vous êtes présents
sur place que vous y avez des usines ou
que vous y avez des supermarchés et vous
savez que vous ne les récupère et
certainement pas quand la crise sera
terminée tout à l'heure on avait évoqué
en début d'émission la différence entre
les états unis les entreprises
américaines les entreprises européennes
et c'est vrai qu'on parlait des
investisseurs à l'instant et du fait que
les investisseurs ont parié contre
l'entreprise qui était sur place parce
que parce qu'il y avait une exposition
qui était forte et un risque qu'ils
étaient forts la question de la
responsabilité joue aussi beaucoup plus
fortement aux etats unis
vous avez depuis depuis des années des
fonds éthiques voire des fonds activiste
proche de mouvances religieuses ou
autres qui refusent d'investir dans un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui ne
respecteraient pas les droits de l'homme
aux autres et ça ça pèse énormément
surtout quand vous avez un système de
retraite par capitalisation
puisque les retraités souhaitent qu'on
prenne le moins de risques possibles
avec l'argent qu'il place pour leur
retraite vous voyez c'est ce capitalisme
financier est très différent de l'europe
en europe mais plutôt des règles en
demandant aux entreprises de respecter
ces règles et c'est très très net
aujourd'hui sur toutes ces
problématiques des droits de l'homme
surtout ces problématiques de lutte
contre le changement climatique etc
c'est vrai que la limite de ces règles
c'est qu'à un moment donné il faut être
en capacité de les faire appliquer la
houle à l'est les fonds d'investissement
et les investisseurs soient ces radicaux
dans leurs choix et quand ils décident
de ne plus investir vous êtes bien
obligé de vous retirer
quelques chiffres encore sur le nombre
de salariés
grands groupes par grands groupes c'est
renault qui en compte le plus en russie
1 46 1800 leroy merlin ces quarante cinq
mille auchan ses 30000 la société
générale dont on parlait tout à l'heure
12000 et danone 8000 je rappelle que
leroy merlin et au chant c'est le même
groupe c c'est la famille mulliez est
comme décathlon est d'ailleurs c'est
plutôt une famille olivier babeau qui
aime rien tant que la discrétion c'est
en terme de communication c'est le parti
des familles les plus discrets dont on
entendra beaucoup parler ouais mais très
souvent les gens qui réussissent
beaucoup et qui ont beaucoup de
patrimoine en fait sont assez discrets
pour plein de raisons alors mes envois
jeu devrait rebondir sur sûr au champ
parce qu'on a on a lu dans le ski yves
clot disait dans cette interview au jdd
il parlait notre mission première c'est
contribuer à nourrir les populations des
deux pays cet argument alimentaire qui
vaut pour auchan tu peut valoir pour
danone d'ailleurs aussi on peut
l'entendre donner une certaine façon oui
d'ailleurs danone qui distribue la
nourriture infantile c'est pas d'essai
pas des roquettes 1,10 produisent un
donc évidemment la question se pose à un
moment donné de la type de sanction vous
voulez faire et et de l'effet de ces
sanctions historiquement les sanctions
contre des pays l ont pas toujours été
très efficace un corée du nord iran cuba
ça n'a jamais fait tomber le régime et
peut-être le cas de l'afrique du sud
éventuellement où on peut dire que ça
les pressions internationales ont aidé
mais sinon les effets essentiels ça a
été une misère noire extrêmement dur
ressentie par les populations jamais par
les dirigeants qui s'arrange toujours
pour avoir une table bien pleine c'est
la question de l'efficacité on dit
continuer à voir une entreprise c'est
soutenir le régime encore vous soutenez
le régime si vous faites de la
distribution de bricolage ben oui vous
payez des impôts et vous vous payer les
salaires de famille russe je vous
intervient qu on n'est plus dans le
symbole de la réussite bien que
l'efficacité oui mais alors je vous
interromps parce que c'est justement
vous parlez de leroy merlin en
l'occurrence
ce tweet du ministère ukrainien de la
défense après le bombardement de leroy
merlin en ukraine et voilà ce qu'ils
disent leroy merlin devient la première
entreprise au monde à financer le
bombardement de ses propres magasins
évidemment cette formule elle marque les
esprits alors vous avez vous nous dire
c'est peut-être pas vrai c'est pas vrai
que leroy merlin finances la guerre de
poutine mais malgré tout cette formule
adresse c'est une interprétation
particulière évidemment vous êtes une
entreprise parmi un très très grand
nombre ou fait partie effectivement de
la machine en vous en allant vous fait
pas un mal seulement énorme à la russie
une façon d'être très très fort sur la
russie ce serait sinon elle était
capable d'arrêter complètement de leur
acheter du gaz on n'en est pas capable
le fait est qu'on a une interdépendance
des travaux des deux côtés est ce que ça
veut dire interdépendantes donc là on
est vraiment encore une fois je pense
dans l'ordre du symbolique et bombe à
l'ukraine peut à bon droit souligne ce
genre de choses mais enfin bon c'est
évidemment forcer un peu
l'interprétation une réaction sur cette
question du gaz on va ouvrir ce chapitre
c'était le président d'énergie mercredi
dernier on est sur france info écouter
ce qu'ils disent sur finalement ce que
les entreprises veulent pas faire et
puis sur la décision des états
si nous décidions on arrêter d'acheter
du gaz russe ça suppose immédiatement
des décisions des pouvoirs publics pour
faire face à une forme de pénurie et du
coup nous sommes vraiment convaincu
c'est une décision qui doit être prise
par la puissance publique est
probablement par l'europe parce que
c'est elle qui a la capacité à prendre
de telles décisions et à l'accompagner
des mesures qui seraient nécessaires
olivier doran on peut peut-être entrer
dans le détail effectivement de ces
contres en matière de gaz des
entreprises françaises c'est le thème de
notre débat avec la russie je le disais
tout à l'heure contrat de longue durée
c'est ça clairement en fait la russie
dans l'est la fin des années 2000
découvert des réserves très importantes
d'hydrocarbures et de gaz dont notamment
dans sa région arctique est investi ou
quand on investit massivement avec des
groupes internationaux on a parlé
effectivement de de angie de total mais
il ya également shell il est ni en
italie bp exane dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui ont investi des peu près
tous les géants les gens investis au
carburant à hauteur de plusieurs
dizaines voire centaines de milliards de
dollars sur ses parades là sur des
contrats excessivement parce qu'il faut
non seulement être enfin de
l'exploration de la production mais du
transport et c'est vrai qu'un des enjeux
du gaz et c'est aussi ce qui complexifie
énormément la donne en terme
d'indépendance énergétique c'est que le
gaz se transporte beaucoup moins
facilement que le pétrole et donc de
fait les les investissements qui ont été
faits on ne porte pas uniquement sur
l'exploration et la production mais
également sur la liquéfaction et sur le
transport c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a annoncé il
ya quelques heures me semble-t-il que le
port du havre
était en train de réfléchir à la
création d'une unité de liquéfaction
pour recevoir justement du gaz naturel
liquéfié et donc les investissements qui
ont été faits sont massifs concernent
énormément de groupes occidentaux dont
des mots français et ils répondent à un
besoin est là où effectivement le le
directeur général de angie a
parfaitement raison c'est que c'est aux
politiques et uniquement politiques de
prendre cette décision là parce que ces
décisions et serait beaucoup trop lourde
de sens si demain par exemple total et
sans vouloir aller dans le sens de
patrick pouyanné si demain total décidé
d'arrêter de s'approvisionner en gaz
auprès de la russie il ne serait plus en
mesure au mondial mettrait un terme à un
engagement contractuel fort avec son
plat ses partenaires locaux d'eau qu'il
aurait des pénalités à ab il aurait des
pénalités qui pourraient potentiellement
être à son tour attraits devant un
tribunal arbitral ou devant un tribunal
judiciaire russe mais au-delà de ces
risques judiciaires il ya également des
risques économiques comment est-ce que
le présent de total peut en tant que
personnes morales privées prend la
décision de faire peser un risque sur
les entreprises françaises qui ont
besoin de ce gala est donc là pour le
coup il n'ya pas d'hypocrisie je pense
dans le discours de ses grands ou majeur
du pétrole et du gaz s'il n'y a pas
décision politique il est inconscient
pour le coup de la part de ces groupes
de sortir et c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles il a été
beaucoup plus simple pour des groupes
comme pépé par exemple qui inquiète qui
appartient au royaume uni de sortir ses
investissements de russie parce que l'on
rémy a décidé comme les états unis de se
passer du gaz russe a une chance
beaucoup plus courte que celle de nyon
européenne mais alors si mu était assis
à une part d'hypocrisie des états dans
dans ce dossier du gaz finalement fait
peser sur les entreprises la pression de
l'opinion pour sortir ou non de la
dépendance au gaz russe alors ce ne sont
pas que les états qui vont peser la
pression c'est on l'a dit les les
sociétés civiles et les parties
prenantes
c'est vrai que dans les sanctions que
nous avons imposées je sais pas si c'est
de l'hypocrisie mais en tout cas on n'a
pas à oser à ce stade aller jusqu'au
bout et c'est pas forcément la france et
l'état français est d'ailleurs parce
qu'on s'en passerait probablement
peut-être pas facilement mais ensemble
on peut s'en passer de manière plus
réaliste que des pays comme l'allemagne
des pays comme l'italie ou les pays
d'europe centrale et orientale
on a décidé de rester unis dans ces
sanctions est donc de continuer à ne pas
sanctionner tout de suite le gaz même si
vous l'avez vu il ya un objectif dans
plusieurs mois de parvenir à réduire nos
importations
finalement cent pendant cette sanction
si on arrive à réduire nos importations
des deux tiers comme l'a annoncé le
président de la commission européenne
c'est une sanction sans être une
sanction donc oui il ya une hypocrisie d
etat quand il s'il venait à exiger des
entreprises de partir puisque en réalité
eux n'osent pas imposer ce type de
sanction et en même temps je crois que
on est tous un peu gêné aux entournures
dans cette situation olivier babeau est
ce que il ya eu des prises de position
officielles pour dire il faut peut-être
se préparer à des ruptures
d'approvisionnement l'hiver prochain
donc sont pas le président de rte les
journaux ce matin
xlt lorenzo à 100 sur réseau transport
électricité sont ceux qui sont postés il
ya trois solutions pour se passer de
l'aide de l'énergie russe soit
évidemment vous importez ça d'ailleurs
notamment des états unis qui sont bien
contents de vendre du gaz de schiste que
nous on s'interdit de produire
nous-mêmes ce paradoxe deuxième chose
c'est qu'on prolonge
évidemment des centrales dans les pays
qui avaient prévu tantôt nucléaire qui
est prévu les arrêter on rouvre
éventuellement des centrales à charbon
c'est pas génial maman pas génial pas
très réjouissant et la troisième c'est
mettre plusieurs pull cet hiver et c'est
probablement et de supporter des
coupures qui vont à distribuer commencer
ce qui était un peu suggérer c'est il va
y avoir une forme de pénurie une forme
de pino in ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on a plus de mal à chauffer qui
avait des moments n'aura peut-être plus
d'électricité c'est quelque chose dont
on avait totalement perdu l'habitude
depuis très longtemps notamment en
france il est possible que ça revienne
si la situation n'évolue pas et si
vraiment on veut que les sanctions soit
efficace c'est à dire si on veut
vraiment réduire cette dépendance est
commandée - ou d'ailleurs s'il boutines
façon d'une autre décide de moins nous
livrer parce que lui aussi c'est une
course à essayer de trouver un peu plus
d'indépendance et c'est de trouver
d'autres débouchés évidemment pour son
gaz au delà pour compléter ce qui vient
d'être dit au delà des coupures dans nos
logements second craint aussi c'est des
fermetures d'usinés en fin d entre eux
deux et ça c'est d'abord sur les
entreprises peut être avant de le faire
sur les ménages de ses parts à genoux
que sont les membres a été dit donc on
sait pas trop mais c'est vrai que si le
gaz n'arrive plus ce sont aussi des
entreprises qui peuvent fermer donc des
personnes qui peuvent se retrouver au
chômage technique
donc on voit il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
que la question de l'otan la température
dans nos logements est le fait que les
vendeurs de pilules risque de bien
vendre leurs pulls l'hiver prochain il
ya aussi de l'activité économique bien
sûr c'est d'ailleurs ce que la schl le
chancelier allemand disait si on
supprime s'il amène ce prix du gaz russe
il ya une récession en allemagne et par
ricochet
est clairement et c'est vrai que je
crois d'ailleurs même que le patrick
pouyanné toujours dans son entretien
avec airtel la semaine dernière a mis en
avant ce risque sur les entreprises
parce que c'est vrai que intuitivement
dans l'opinion publique on pense aux
coupures de chauffage et d'ailleurs aux
injonctions de certains hommes
politiques vu que ça s'entrechoquent
avec la campagne que nous sommes en
train de vivre de baisser son chauffage
de 1 ou 2 degrés comment certains ont pu
inviter les français à le faire que les
français avaient souvent d'ailleurs déjà
fait depuis quelques jours parce que
l'électricité vous avez critique pour
réduire la fac mais c'est vrai que le
risque majeur est l'agent de tafer si le
métier est ce que dit le changer les
choses c'est le sait sur les entreprises
parce qu on a une un tissu industriel
alors moins qu'en allemagne certes mais
on a un tissu industriel qui est encore
très dépendants de ces énergies là et
donc la question qui se pose c'est si on
n'a pas suffisamment de gaz pour faire
fonctionner ou de d'hydrocarbures pour
faire fonctionner son entreprise on va
devoir les mettre à l'arrêt en mettant à
l'arrêt on va mettre des gens au chômage
technique on va donc avoir une
augmentation des charges au niveau de
l'état français et une éventuelle
peut-être pas récession parce qu'on est
dans une période de forte croissance
notamment du fait de la crise due qu'aux
vives en tout cas on aura un
ralentissement assez notable de la
croissance en france merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'était passionnant il va bose
rappel le titre de votre livre les
nouveaux désordres numérique on est sur
une autre thématique mais passionnante
elle aussi comment le digital fait
exploser les inégalités
et c'est publié aux éditions buchet
chastel